adventuretime fee logs that's right uh
the Avatar be logs went over really well
people are asking me to do another one
and I've been asking around trying to
see like which one you know which show
do people want me to do it cuz it was
fun and I got introduced to a new
wonderful show uh and one night keep
seeing a conventions everywhere and
people keep talking about they dress up
like the characters they talk about they
asked me about all the time is adventure
time and I got the seasons right here
and just like the avatar V logs before
I'm gonna go through everyday or as much
as possible I might miss a day or two um
and I'm just gonna go through every
single episode and talk about it and I
know there's a lot of people out there
like well how can you do a comedic show
you can't analyze comedy comedy it's
just magic it just is and it's
subjective so you can't talk about
you know there's so much stuff
that people like all cause of subjective
it can't be discussed and comedy is one
of them you have it or you don't either
think it's funny or you don't and I do
not agree with that
there's a reason Charlie Chaplin is
still around after all these years
there's reason Three Stooges are still
around and Jerry Lewis and all these
famous comedians are still being
discussed long after they're gone uh and
just to say it's just magic it is
you don't go into a museum and
aren't using and be like oh why is the
Mona Lisa so powerful why's that hold up
oh it just does that's it
now people write books about this
and comedy is exactly the same so I'm
gonna go throughout the comedy and the
story and the characters of adventure
time and I'll just give you uh my
lead-in right now to the show I've seen
like maybe half an episode something
like that and it was weird it was very
weird and I just said to myself okay I
probably just had to see this from the
beginning I I don't know because it was
very very odd so this isn't like avatar
where I saw a bit of I'm like oh that
looks like a really good show I wanna
you know uh watch it you know on top of
everybody saying it was great no I I
have no idea what this show is about I
have no understanding of it I just know
it's weird I hear it's kind of like Ren
Stimpy with a story sort of like Ren
Stimpy the fantasy epic so I have no
idea what to expect going into this I
just know people talk about it they
dress up like the characters they love
it they love talking about they love
asking me about it if I've seen it uh so
obviously there's something to it and at
the very least if I don't like the show
which is totally possible you never know
um at the very least it's fun talking
about why other people like it and why
it caught on because it really is caught
on you go to any convention and they're
just all over the place so I'm curious
it's piqued my interest and a lot of
people been asking me to do it so uh
next couple months here these are gonna
be the Adventure Time vie logs uh just
everyday as much as possible I'm gonna
post an episode a gas knock I always be
at the very top it'll be among the other
producers so scroll through and then
look for it and yeah
pray for me cuz this looks like a very
bizarre show so um I'll see you in I bet
your time or wherever this take place